who's god do you i'm glad you just asked
that question because
i actually
i'm gonna have to make a a
distinguishable separation here
all right
um and it's funny because i heard
recently uh
i heard a rabbi was
debating with uh this historian dr ben i
can't put in stock the band name but it
was debating
and in that debate
they started going back through the
etymology
they went way back beyond antiquity
because they was debating so there was
you know some things they was going deep
and they really went far far back to
kind of the first word of
of god
[Music]
and it was
when they pronounced it on this
particular debate it was allah
and they said for that they got elohim
um i've already
agreed in my heart in my life
that
the father this universe proper name is
allah
um and of course in the law i get all
you know um and i don't think that
god
is the same as that i think a law gives
birth to god
in fact if you take the word allah a l l
h
and you take it through numerology or
numbers the number a being letter a
being 1 l being 12 and you add it all up
to its
lowest uh to the you know the last
denominator you're gonna get the number
seven
and the number seven is going to bring
you right back to that letter g
so a law aborns god but god don't bone
allah
how does how does that god how does
allah connect to the oracle
the that you're you're going to be
calling for when you're laying in the
hospital well what i was saying in that
particular verse was that
we're looking for the oracle we're
looking for somebody else or something
to help us that nobody can really help
you at the end of the day
you know
and we're speaking on on so now that we
i don't want to say we're speaking on
religion but we're speaking on a way of
life and a way of thinking
uh
and i've read many books of course you
and i could say there's no book
that
my
the book that is the most strongest book
i've ever read is actually the holy
quran
it's stronger to me than my bible which
i read
is stronger than quantum physics which
i've read is stronger than the
bhagavad-gita it's just and and i read
once uh a british scholar said it's the
most stupidest book ever written
and
it doesn't make sense
and uh so i said oh i see why he says
that though i can understand exactly why
he said that as well
why is that
because the the structure of the words
are just
it's peculiar
you know i mean but it's almost like how
some people's songs you don't really
know exactly what they say until years
later yeah
uh yeah you have uh actually joe rogan i
think you talked about how uh
a joke of dave chappelle's hit you like
a long time after this so this is kind
of like the quran it it uh i i tend to
believe that we
human beings cannot possibly understand
anything as big as
these ideas so um i just
i don't know do you think that
like are you humble in the face of just
the the immensity of it
to be honest yes
i'm humble in the face of the
you can say the world are going to
pronounce words funny
the omni the omnipotence
essence the
magnitude
i'm humbled in the face of in the face
of allah
the problem that
i may have had was that i wasn't humbled
in the face of god because
it's just a definable thing
and that's why i think a lot of us and
i'm saying that you know i know when we
say god we're trying to say a lot
like people was saying that but you're
actually not saying the same thing
because you're actually putting
something beside
and
and that's the reason why you can have
all this many guards
you can find a whole bunch of them
yeah i mean but you're not going to find
many there's nobody beside allah i mean
law is one so
i know it's the whole thing but that's
my heart is is there i'm humbled by it
i'm at peace with it
uh and it doesn't take nothing or
demerit anything from myself
that's the beauty of it it doesn't take
nothing from me from being who so if i
say
if somebody walk up your peace god i
could take that because they're telling
me that y'all i'm a man of wisdom i'm a
man of strength i'm a man of beauty
or some attribute of that you know what
i mean so it will turn a god's a wrap
there's wisdom there there's strength
there there's beauty that we'll take
that
you